what I find fascinating is that you have
this one location where so many things
are happening and it's documented by a
bunch of government people a bunch of
PhD scientists a bunch of people that
have lived there and um and not only
documented over like a few months we're
talking like decades you know and it's
kind of a hot spot where you can kind of
dig into trying to find why are they all
happening at this one location and and
what interests me is that I think it
gives us a potential path way to discuss
some alternate um candidates for where
they're from or what they're doing or
how it all works like I think most
people like to think of UFOs is they're
coming from another planet you know we
found an exoplanet it's coming there and
how do they travel well they could do it
in 30 years if they go fast well the
data doesn't seem to suggest that really
it it it it's more what's happening at
Skinwalker where it seems like it's more
about frequencies and dimensional or the
materialized it's almost like they're
displacement craft that displaces our
time like a submarine would in the ocean
um and that was a lot of what Dr halud
worked on on atip was understanding the
attributes of the propulsion and the
science that they're using and I think
once you think about UFOs using that
kind of a
technology then it's kind of like well
if they do that if they use that that
means there's things that are adjacent
to us that we don't see that we don't
understand but are like right here and
every once in a while they can kind of
cross over is it because we're aware of
it and can see it and that opens it or
is it because it's a
geomagnetic area where where those types
of things have an easier time coming
through um or is it everywhere and we
just think it's in one location I don't
know I mean there's a story that even
happened there where they like you know
they were there and they and you're
talking about government grade phds
where they watch you know something in
the atmosphere open up and something
come through not sure what it is and and
it was a huge event so they run down to
grab the cameras and see what was on the
cameras they open up these locked boxes
and then like all the electronics are
missing in the cameras and they're like
wait what like these were locked up and
who took it's like a game and so it gets
really interesting where is it a game I
don't know but it might be a
Consciousness thing and so I get
passionate about a a place like that
because it gives you the ability to do
to really jump into some wild stuff I
mean one of the scientists there was
walking through a field and they
basically saw um you know they saw they
walked past um like a cow or something
and then they turn around it was gone
and then like 10 minutes later they're
like where is it they turn back around
and there it is on the ground just out
of nowhere with like two broken legs so
they run in to gra alive it was no it
was alive you know and then they run
back into the the house to go grab a gun
or something to take care of it and when
they come out and now it has four broken
legs you know or something it's like
creepy and and and like causing alarm
because it number one it makes no sense
number two it's like it's happening so
quick that they can't even um and I got
family showing up from the beach you
know you see people behind me but um you
mentioned the beach they all went to the
beach earlier but um what it seems to be
is that it's it's you know an issue with
time um and an issue with moving it like
from here to here where we can't see it
and back and then people will see crap
and then I don't know it's it's just
wild and it and it's so fascinating and
I always tell people in Hollywood
because you know two the stars is
getting into making like movies and TV
series and documentaries and stuff and I
just go you don't need to sensationalize
this stuff you don't need to come up
with um like like science fiction type
um you know ideas to make it intriguing
I mean it's it is it's it's wild the way
it is you don't have to do much to it